prince harry wiping away tears as he
honors his grandmother queen elizabeth
this is a family
in mourning now and
of course
the queen was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother
on wednesday the duke of sussex walked
the streets of london with his brother
prince william his father king charles
and his three siblings to bring the late
monarch's coffin from buckingham palace
to westminster hall
her majesty the queen approved all plans
for her service with charles in advance
neither megan nor kate walked the route
along with the family princess anne was
the only female allowed which is
actually a sign of how the late queen
has moved things forward for women once
inside the brothers wives kate middleton
and meghan markle were by their side for
the service
[Music]
when his grandmother's coffin arrived at
the hall harry couldn't hold back tears
megan then showed support holding her
husband's hand as they exited the
service behind william and kate i think
from that we can read that every effort
is being made by the royal family to
include the sussexes in this historic
poignant and deeply moving time for the
royal family
harry and meghan have been estranged
from the family since their decision to
step down as senior royals but in the
wake of the queen's death they've come
back together first with harry making a
trip to balmoral castle in scotland
alone after hearing of his grandmother's
declining health he didn't make it in
time to see her before she died and
shortly after megan and harry were
invited by william to join him and kate
to greet mourners outside of windsor
castle
this is the first time they have been
together and really since the duke of
edinburgh's funeral nearly 18 months ago
i suppose everyone will be will be
hoping that there can be some sort of a
reconciliation it's just a tragedy that
it comes across the queen's deathbed the
rift between william and harry is a rift
that has run deep which has ripped apart
the windsor family caused the queen
great sadness um
will there be a reconciliation i think
at the moment it's difficult to tell